Nó này 1 người tháng 12 năm, mang chỉ vì bộ đội viết phòng tình lai châu phối hợp với chúng ta mọi lại,
về thế vị khác, tổ chức tập hấn ký năng số chocan bộ, chế dí,
đại ta chương miên đức, chỉ vì trưởng mang chỉ vì bộ đội viết phòng tình lai châu dự, phát biểu chỉ đạo.
Tập hấn nhận trong vị trocan bộ, chế dí kinh thức, ký năng cơ bản về bản hàng,
trong tâm là bản hàng trực biến, qua đó hỗ trợ như dân cư tục bây giờ quảng má, dưới thiệu,
tự thủ sản phẩm biệt phương. Tại bội tập hấn, tại ta chương miên đức nhấn mạnh,
cấp ý, chỉ vì các cơ quan đơn vị cân đương càng nhận thức,
sau định gió chính hiện trong lãnh đạo, chỉ đạo, tập trung bộ giữ cho cán bộ,
chế dí kinh thức, ký năng bản hàng trực sản phương hại địa tự, làm năng có tướng giấn,
hỗ trợ như dân phai thác hiệu quả các niệm tảng số,
để quảng má, dưới thiệu tự thủ sản phẩm biệt phương,
có phần thực hiện tháng lợi dí vụ phát triển kinh tế, sau hội,
bỏ vệ vấn chắc chụ quyền lãnh thủ, anh em bây giờ cuốc gia.
Sau mùi tập hấn, các học viên đi tự tế tại bản số lịch sinh thái xí suy hồ,
bán tổ chức lợi trọt bà đến năm bộ dân có sản phẩm đặc trương của điều phương,
trình vị sản phẩm chiên bài, để đàn công tác thức khai nướng giấn ký năng bản hàng trực tiến.
Nhưng gì thế này, ông viện xun tụng, giả nước chú tâm on lai chờ tạm mộ lội biệt phòng tình
lại cho 2 chăm mát sử dụng uống dụng v vệ tế về program,
chỉ giá một chăm sóm viện lòng.